hi guys and girls today I'm going to
talk about a reading and how it can be
greatly beneficial for my customers
there's no doubt the reading is great
for anybody regardless of you want to
learn whether you want to learn the
language or not but today I'm going to
focus on one cool technique which is
called intensive reading which can be
greatly beneficial for you if you want
to improve your language skills so to
say and I'm going to lay out some
important criteria on what to do and how
to do intensive reading which is really
important first of all what is intensive
reading intensive reading is a way of
reading text for the with the aim of
deconstructing it and learn as much as
you can extract as much information as
you can from the text namely a
vocabulary or sentences or even sounds
if you're listening pronunciation if
you're listening to the audio now the
goal of intensive reading is to get out
of your comfort zone and basically learn
as much as you can and move on so if you
say it at b1 and you want to move to B 2
you will read certain texts through your
B 2 you will read other texts now what
to read intensive reading you should
actually tackle context content that is
short and a bubble interesting so first
of all it must be interesting otherwise
you're not going to read it it's not
like school so you can choose your own
text you can find your own content and
you should be short so that you can
spend some time on it focusing on the
constructs in it and you shouldn't it
shouldn't spend too much time the
shorter the text of the better in this
regard so how long which leads to the
other point how long well you shouldn't
read for more than 15 to 30 minutes
because your concentration after 30
minutes goes down so the length of text
and how long are strictly connected as I
said before the level should be slightly
higher than yours or even higher than
yours so that you're going to stumble
upon a bunch of work that you don't know
or or grammatical
constructions that you're not familiar
with and another couple of tips which
are really important is waiting to do
that you should do that when you are
fresh that is your energy fluctuates
during the day and you should try to
create time slots in which your energy
is high so that you feel like doing that
because if you do when you're retired or
worn out that's not going to happen and
the last thing last but not least is the
position of your body you should try to
find a position of your body which
allows you to stay focused
for example laying down of the bed or C
sprawled on the couch is not exactly the
best position possibly just sitting in
front of your desk it doesn't have to be
feel like a chore but you have to find a
position once again of your body which
allows you to stay focused stay present
and basically learn you can find an
awesome article that I wrote with
together with my friend Kevin Morehouse
on my blog
and you can find the link in the
description box below thank you very
much for listening have a fantastic day
and I'm going to talk to you very soon
in the next video I'm going to talk
about extensive therapy thank you once
again and talk to you very soon bye
you